it's great to be joined today by Newton
Avedon who's the founder and CEO of Orca
Natanz so interesting to talk to you you
know one of the issues that I'm seeing
that that's taking place right now not
only in the financial world generally
but also within the crypto world is that
in order to manage all of your payment
methods crypto assets etc it's become
extraordinarily fragmented and I think
it's actually sort of an impediment to
people even getting involved in this
world to some degree they need this
exchange and that wallet and this
browser plug-in etc talk to us a little
bit about that problem and sort of what
you're looking to do as a solution to
that yes so basically the main you know
solution and the main problem that we're
tackling you named it you know it's is
the thing that everybody would trade
crypto we use this you know any crypto
currency or you know want to move crypto
currency from the exchange to their bank
account normally they have at least two
or three bank accounts and three or four
exchange account because different banks
have different email compliance policies
compliance policies kyc procedures and
etc and for crypto users it becomes more
and more tricky to use cryptocurrencies
so we're kind of trying to create this
bridge between crypto and fiat and also
while doing that we realized that there
is a one more challenge that people have
like 10 logins five logins and two in
order to change all their balances it
takes them around one hour one and a
half hour to go through all their
exchanges in all their bank accounts and
just to have overview of what how much
money do basically have and this is what
we realized we need to solve and in open
banking concept fits very well in this
in for for this solution
so yeah this is this is basically what
we're doing we're connecting all the
accounts to one dashboard and providing
users with a 360 overview of their
financial data do you think that this is
part of what has restricted adoption of
cryptocurrency whether it's for online
payment or a stores of value or for sort
of transnational transactions that go
beyond country borders that there's a
sort of difficulty of actually figuring
out how many tools do I even need to
take some Fiat convert it into crypto
get it into the right exchange and
ultimately to the right people or for
the right purpose I feel that this is
significantly holding down adoption of
course I mean for for regular like user
Fiat user let's say even like choosing
the right crypto and finding it is
already a challenge if you are not going
for etherium or or Bitcoin you go for
like top 30 top 40 coins you need to
look for them you need to search for
them in different exchanges and then
once you bought them where do you move
them how do you come back and check on
them like what can you do now this is
the questions that people are asking and
we see it we see a huge gap here and
basically we we call this problem that
crypt we say like internally would say
the crypto is not user friendly yet and
this is the exact reason that for
regular user that basically who is not
used to going into different exchanges
having to identify gation looking into
all the speakers it's just it's just a
mess it's just too much information
too much - too many different user
interfaces and that that's what we are
solving we're creating a unified
interface to bring this to make this one
more step towards mass adoption can you
talk a little bit about the security
angle here because you know there's
understandably sort of skittishness
concern from people about the security
we hear about massive
there's also small hacks we were even
the victims of a much smaller hack a few
weeks ago that some in our audience
actually know about so I think that it
would be sort of a immediate question
that people would have which is if you
have one platform here the Orca
dashboard the Orca platform which allows
you to move funds between accounts to
use Fiat to buy crypto vice versa
etc what is the sort of security
infrastructure of that and ultimately
who is holding the crypto when people
are using your platform so we are not
holding money or crypto I mean Peter or
crypto we're only providing an access to
user account for example if you have it
an account with finance we would take
the API key and access your account
advance through our dashboard so you
would basically see the balance but the
money the crypto is going to be at the
exchange same goes with the banking
accounts if you have euros we would
access the balance account information
and will basically see the numbers but
we won't keep the money and same goes
with transaction initiation if we can
initiate transaction from your bank
account to finance but we won't
the money will go straight from your
bank account to finance without we won't
touch the money like they will go
straight so what we basically what
access we have we have access to your
information to information about the
account balance but we don't store it
basically we show it to you and we have
intent encryption and in order to login
into the system you need to do to a fee
or certification and each time you do it
you basically kind of send the
permission to access to API keys to
access their API keys so now we store
very little of information and it's
basically not vulnerable one of the main
features of the Oracle platform is this
marketplace that exists for apps what is
talked to us a little bit about that
what are the types of apps that will be
available how will they interact with
platform so marketplace is something
it's one more step towards user mass
adoption let's say that because for now
we see a lot of different very cool
projects that are doing different
financial services on blockchain crypto
lending and etc but most of the time in
order to use them or when they will
deliver the product in order to use it
you will need to have their token
meaning that if you use like 5 10 20
different services you need always to
keep these 10 tokens 10 different tokens
in your wallet go around different
exchanges buy them so we don't we think
this is not really convenient this is
why we created a marketplace where we
have all these different crypto
financial services and we integrate
their token without token using banker
liquidity protocol so when you go to the
marketplace you just need one token Orca
token to access all these services and
these services are salt lending a blend
SDK and more and more and more services
that you can also buy trading algorithms
that will that you will attach to your
exchange API and they will trade for you
like follow trend arbitrage algorithms
because we can see different exchanges
different accounts there and we can do
arbitrage also not we but the algorithms
and this is the why we see a clear need
for marketplace because what we're doing
here we're trying to solve certain
problems to tackle certain challenges
and the marketplaces act is for sure
solving ones so where does the token
come into all this what does it do and
and what what utility does it have so
the main utility as I mentioned it has
because you can access the the apps on
the marketplace you can access them like
for example if there is let's say I
don't know F land and you want to use
you need land
tokens we would integrate bank through
bankroll equality protocol would
integrate land tokens with Orca tokens
and we would just do the swap for you so
you would paid with Orca tokens but we
would do the exchange and you would be
able to use the service what about the
ICO what's the sort of status of the ICO
at this point so we're doing a private
sale currently it's going pretty well we
almost closed it I think we'll close it
in two weeks maybe in ten days and from
then we'll announce that the date of the
public sale so we're looking into mid or
late June and yeah that's that's the
sale that's new and as far as the other
internal uses of the token and just sort
of other features that are built on to
the platform there's this sort of
gamification component the quest
community program can you talk about how
that works yeah so the quest part is
basically where we engage with the
community where it's it's a part where
any developer for example can say you he
has an idea for trading algorithm or he
has his own trading algorithm he wants
to share with the community he would go
to this part of the platform to the
quest part and he would say I need like
a small amount of money to build this to
adopt to make it user-friendly you have
a nice interface and the users would
fund let's say two thousand three
thousand dollars worth of tokens and he
will be you know delivering the
algorithm and if in the user users who
have the ability to use it so it's we
feel that crypto is very much based on
the community like it started from
Bitcoin we had a small community of
people who believed in in and community
is always a big part of cryptocurrency
so we feel we need we need to integrate
community into the classroom can you
talk a little bit about sort of parallel
to the ICO and the token sale
where is the development of the platform
itself in other words what all of the
things we've talked about what are the
sort of timelines for when those things
will be a reality
so if basically what we're doing now
we're working very hard to deliver the
platform as soon as possible we have a
roadmap where we are launching the first
version of the platform in August but we
feel that we might even do it earlier
because things are going very well
our team is growing and we have a very
skilled and experienced developers I
believe we're gonna we're gonna have the
platform like the first version up and
running early always maybe mid August
but before that next week we're gonna
introduce something very very exciting
we just basically cracked the solution
for we instant cash withdrawal from
several big exchanges and we're gonna
showcase how it works we have we're
gonna have a press conference and and
and we'll share the information with our
community but this is something very big
that we're very excited to showcase next
week would you say that the Orca
platform is geared primarily towards
managing crypto with the connection to
Fiat bank account or do you see it as
sort of both a crypto and fiat platform
equally it's designed for cryptocurrency
users of course we focus mainly on
cryptocurrency users but also you know
for those who use fiat and maybe one
turn through cryptocurrency world this
is a good gate to the crypto world but
mainly yes the answer would be we are
designing this platform for
cryptocurrency community last thing I
want to touch on so of course you're
focusing significantly on sort of like
making it simpler to have higher user
adoption in the crypto space other than
just user adoption what do you think is
the sort of another make-or-break sort
of element for crypto is it perceived
security is it solving some of the you
know resource issues that
exist with the mining of some crypto
currencies like Bitcoin like aside from
just how many people are using it what
else do you believe will be make or
break for the crypto world I believe
it's regulation this is something that
you know there is a clear lack of
regulation and governments and
regulators they do not really as we see
it now they don't understand how it
works and they're trying to do some of
the government's aren't letting just go
and and in in looking where it leads the
community and and and and then will try
to regulate that some governments just
ban it and then see we know the examples
perfectly and then just look trying to
figure out what to do with the criminal
activity that is happening because of
the ban but yeah we we believe that
regulation I personally believe that
regulation is a big thing and we're
looking forward towards a smart
regulation and we are actually talking a
lot with regulators trying to help them
educating them by educating them and you
know it's all about sharing the
information and and helping the
regulators the government's to figure
out how to use crypto how to track
crypto how to avoid criminal decrypt and
if you when this is going to be solved
we'll see a mass adoption of perfect
super interesting project we've been
speaking with Netanyahu dan who's the
founder and CEO of Orca you can find out
more using the links in the video
description 'not on thanks so much for
talking to us about this thanks for
having